a lot has changed in the last two years
back then covet was a novel disease that
we didn't know too much about or how to
treat fast forward to now and that's no
longer the case
let's go over seven ways the science and
our understanding of covet has evolved
plus i'll share what those changes mean
for how we prevent transmission what's
outdated and what's not and why most
countries are unlikely to see lockdowns
again
one symptoms
at the beginning of the pandemic
checking for symptoms like a dry cough
or a fever was a go-to spread prevention
strategy that was in large part because
we thought only people with symptoms
could spread covet we now know that
people without symptoms can definitely
spread covet plus since then we've
learned that the data on symptom checks
is murky epidemiologists don't know how
well daily questionnaires work at
catching potential cases that's because
they're only as good as people's honesty
plus there's very little scientific
evidence that temperature checks alone
do anything to prevent transmission
that's because many people don't get a
fever or are asymptomatic
two
tests
back in 2020 tests were really hard to
come by there were long lines at testing
sites and only people with certain
symptoms could get tested while we've
experienced more recent testing
shortages at-home rapid tests are now
available to practically everybody
especially if you can afford to buy them
yourself some employers are giving their
workers test kits so they can swap
themselves regularly or when they have
symptoms the federal government has also
made them available for free plus rapid
tests are currently covered by insurance
three treatments
better access to rapid tests has made
the long-awaited test to treat strategy
for covett prevention possible in april
2020 that wasn't an option because
at-home treatments didn't exist since
then pharmaceutical giants pfizer and
merck have come out with anti-covet
pills that reduce the risk of
hospitalization and death and the
earlier they're taken the better with
these new antivirals available at
pharmacies people who test positive can
immediately start taking these pills at
home without needing to go to the
hospital in march the biden
administration launched the tested treat
program to make these pills more widely
available through local pharmacies
nursing homes and community health
centers now we also have vaccines these
three things together testing antivirals
and vaccines lower our collective risk
and they're the reason why at least in
the u.s we're unlikely to see lockdowns
again
four clean air
the emphasis on clean air is arguably
the biggest update to our public health
guidance on kovitt transmission when the
pandemic started public health experts
thought that transmission happened
through large respiratory droplets that
fell out of the air within three to six
feet the thinking was that for the virus
to transmit these large virus-laden
droplets had to land on somebody's eyes
nose or mouth and from there the virus
would infect your cells now we know that
the virus is airborne meaning it can
float around in the air for a long time
and over distances longer than six feet
so now airflow experts say that upgrades
to a building's ventilation and air
filtration systems are key to preventing
the spread of covid even more than they
thought at the beginning of the pandemic
five social distancing
remember the three to six feet we were
talking about earlier one hallmark of
the early pandemic response were markers
and signs telling you to keep that
distance from other people that stemmed
from how we thought the virus spread
through those large respiratory droplets
that i mentioned earlier in some places
like the train or maybe your office some
of that signage remains and that's
because social distancing helps to an
extent but infectious disease experts
say that it's less about distancing and
more about density fewer people means
less virus floating around in the air
which means lower risk of transmission
that's why crowded spaces are still
potential hot spots for spread
especially if they're not well
ventilated or the air isn't filtered
6. masks
the guidance on masking has been
influenced in part by supply chains and
the realization that the virus is
airborne in early 2020 masks were really
hard to come by especially the n95
variety which are the best masks of all
so public health experts including
anthony fauci said that the general
public didn't need to wear masks that
changed in early april 2020 when the
trump administration asked people who
lived in covet hot spots to wear cloth
masks on a voluntary basis since then
multiple studies have shown that wearing
masks indoors lowers the risk of
transmission recently several states
have done away with their mass mandates
including in schools due in part because
of the availability of vaccines and
lower case counts infectious disease
experts warn that if cases pick back up
we may need to put them back on
especially indoors or if other
precautions aren't in place
7. hygiene
another big early pandemic prevention
strategy was cleanliness think back to
the shortages of hand sanitizer and
wipes we used to think that the virus
could survive on surfaces for a long
time because there were early studies
that showed viral genetic material on
surfaces that turned out to be just
remnants not live virus capable of
infecting there's a very low risk of
catching covet through contaminated
surfaces by some estimates it's one in
ten thousand a lot has changed since the
beginning of the pandemic and it's
important to remember that no one
protocol is going to keep us infection
free plus we need to stay flexible as
coveted waves go up and down
[Music]